so i'm joined now bye farida and hameed
well welcome to both of you to piers
morgan uncensored uh freda let me just
start with you if i may
what is your understanding of what the
new taliban ruling is in relation to
female television presenters in
afghanistan
thank you so much
last week
the taliban announced a new decree
and restriction on performance
especially for
the women's who are appearing on the
screens and they presenting the news or
other social programs
so my understand from these
degrees that the taliban want to remove
this step-by-step from public life
and they decided that
women should be just sitting at home and
they are not allowed to go out this is
my understanding and this is a big
concern which i have about this
issue of degrees that the taliban just
in nine past
months
they just putting on the comments
hamid you
and other male presenters decided that
you were going to protest
on behalf of your female colleagues by
also
wearing masks on air tell me about that
decision
by the time when we received the decree
when we are we were ordered to
especially our female colleagues to mask
on while on air so we collectively
collectively decided to go for a strike
and support our female colleagues of
this very critical situation and that
the message that we want to come through
with this move
was to relate the the fact authorities
that this is not the way that they want
to impose islam for us or they want to
define this time and at this very
critical situation women especially our
female character did not feel alone that
no one is there behind to support them
all together we decided we went on air
with mask up and it was it has
very huge uh reactions or uh on the
social media as well we were being
supported by the uh civil community as
well uh
we decided we went on that we supported
them and we will
do that we ended the
protest though but still we have the
same stunts on that we still want to
support our female colleagues at any
time
with any means that we can do it that
was a civil gesture
because we knew
there are so many different and
misinterpretation of hijab
uh that's why we oppose them
if it's uh something uh we never opposed
any degree by the taliban why we opposed
this case because um there is no clear
definition
they have to uh clear it what is hijab
hijab in islam for us we are also
muslims we as well know what is hijab
for female colleagues like hijab is to
cover the whole body the entire body
except like from forehead to chin it's
all fine their hands it should be
visible it's not a big deal
like putting masks or asking them to
wear mask is something that they want to
gradually remove women from the society
or they don't want them to give the
rights that they have as in human beings
and this is a small step being taken by
the
de facto authorities in order to
facilitate for a bigger move the bigger
move i mean is that
maybe in a very short span of time they
will be asked just to not
uh
appear on the screen anymore or just
they will be asked to set inside homes
and you are not allowed to get out of
your homes without any female female and
muharram as they already clearly stated
that so that's why we
protested and so we ended that but still
we have the same
our view hasn't been changed on the
matter
as long as we are
we do not satisfy with a clear
interpretation of hijab we will support
this
and we will still remain on our stance
very clearly
well i mean i think it's very courageous
of
you men to be doing this in support of
your female colleagues frieda let me ask
you it's also very courageous for both
of you to be speaking out to the world's
media
in the way that you are right now are
you not concerned or fearful
of what the taliban may do if you do
interviews like this
yeah i'm
concerned i said that
before that the taliban announced uh
degrees about the hijab they are get
steps some
other
announced other
orders about performance and especially
girls they close the
schools for the girls they just
remove
all the
organizations support the women's and
now they announced that the woman while
they appearing on the screen they should
be covering their face
and in this order they clearly said that
the best hijab is worker that the woman
should be wearing burka the things that
is impossible while we are training on a
screen just be wearing a worker this is
impossible and we are we have affair
that when the taliban just uh watching
this interview they will be
uh
take some actions like now uh while the
our male colleagues wearing masks they
have some issues like they and the
social media they posted that
while uh male colleagues wearing masks
they should be wearing shawl or they
should be wearing work as well that they
showed their solidarity with their
female colleagues
so we have a concern not just about the
our security job like we will be lost
our job we have other
other security fairs and maybe the
target us or maybe they target other
family members uh we are concerned about
all these things
well i think it's extremely courageous
of you both
to be doing this and freda let me ask
you that when i had the taliban
spokesman suhail shaheen on my program
recently he was adamant that you know
women had nothing to be fearful about
that
they would be supportive
towards women and the
girls would be allowed back to school
in high school are you seeing any
evidence of any of this
when the de facto authority of the
taliban these books by the some foreign
international media or others they
uh say that uh we working on the policy
that closed or that open schools for the
senior girls or the
girls
and all around the country and they said
we will be work on the policy that how
the women can work on the
governmental organizations and private
organizations they say that we work on
the policy that's how make it the
private the proper way that the woman
work household who they just
say about the policy but look in the
past nine months what the taliban do for
the women's they just gave
orders they just gave uh they just issue
a decrease and they
put more restriction and limitation on
the woman's
but in afghanistan maybe their families
out of afghanistan they go to schools
they go to universities and they just
analyzing these situations and they
never come to afghanistan like i never
have saved sohail shaheen come to
afghanistan they just what is going on
in afghanistan
i i showed that he never come to
afghanistan just they talk with
international media from online and they
have a uh other uh
maybe something that they have some
immunity and
in the foreign countries and they never
come to afghanistan they just give how
the situation are going on and when they
talk they never talk about what is
reality in afghanistan i'm in
afghanistan i'm in kabul and uh around
the world the people now say mistake
watching us that we're covering our face
just you ask soheil shaheen that you
said that we
will allow all girls that they should go
into school we work on a policy that the
woman should be work on the private and
governmental organization but why you
put more restriction on the permits like
wiring
why are they appearing on the screens
they should be covering with their base
and
this 21st century around the world the
country get promotions and development
but in afghanistan it's like a kind of
joke that the woman while they appearing
on the screen they should be covering
their face
um when
as a woman when i analyze these
situations i think that the taliban just
vacating with us like they showed the
world
they do that kind of extremism actions
like uh they do in a remote treaty of
afghanistan now they are in kabul they
do the same action with us and they
obligated us to wearing our face
and hamid finally uh and briefly if you
don't mind what is your view of the
decision by president biden to withdraw
all the american forces overnight and
indeed britain and other forces withdrew
as well it was so sudden and seemed to
just surrender the country back to the
taliban what is your your view of that
so they would have left even maybe
that decision was taken by
that government is something that they
would not stay here forever in
afghanistan they were supposed to live
someday but left in a very quiet
situation that the world knows how the
people were suffering you know they
built 20 years the government here with
all with trillions of dollars spent with
thousands of lives
lost here in afghanistan but they give
and they give up in a very very very
simple way and they
left or they handed over the government
to the people that they were fighting
over 20 years with them and they
considered them as a terrorist or
whatever they called them
uh no one accepted that no one expected
something that will happen to the
afghans anywhere they came right now the
talibans or the de facto authorities in
the country now they should take some
various steps not limiting the woman's
issue only we have humanitarian crisis
here we are fixed economical situation
here in the country people are angry
people do not have food to eat
they just focus on on the woman issues
they're just trying to crack down the
woman from the society or whatever they
want to do they have to take some bigger
steps they have to
make a better relationship with the
international community they should take
a better steps in order to have a good
uh relationship with the outside world
in order to recognize their government
if they keep doing this thing i'm sure
that
no one or no country in the world will
recognize them and we people will suffer
the way we are suffering the people are
suffering their government anyway they
can survive but they should think about
the nation that they are going through a
very difficult situation at the moment
women's are not only the part of the
society that you're focusing on there
are other issues that i've already
mentioned that
so better uh they should uh do something
for this country now their thirties now
they have responsibility government
coming to the power or ruling the people
is is not just
something that they have to do they have
a bigger responsibility they used to
fight a government they used to fight
international community with guns now
they have to provide the facility for
these people the nation that
that that that suffered a lot when they
were fighting you know the international
community we were the victims of war and
right now we are the victims of politics
as well we suffer a lot and we have very
small gains right now we have to save
them people were thinking that the
taliban have changed even the
international community thought that
that
back in in the mid 1990s when they were
ruling us so once they came here on the
power on the very first day i remember
it was 17th august where their
spokesperson very clearly said that the
women's will have their rights the
people will have their rights they will
make afghanistan better there will be
future for the afghans but these things
were all i think i think they forgot
what they have promised the people on
the very first day people were very
eager that okay a new government came
the war ended there's no killing there's
no bloodshed but right now nothing as
such no word no bloodshed but we the
people are hungry the people are going
into the very difficult situation they
should take care of such things they
should think that okay right now 30
million nearly 40 million people are
living in this geography so they need
service they need
even
if they want to like remove women from
the public it means that they want to
eradicate the half of population of the
country of the population within the
past 20 years helped the nation to
progress they just they contributed a
lot very actively in the society how
come you just
with a degree in an issue you want to
remove them from the society they helped
us a lot and leave them and everyone as
like fired at herself sitting behind me
here like by my side
she studied for more than 20 years she
suffered a lot she wanted to have a
future in the country she wanted to work
for the bitter men or for the progress
of this country for the for for the
people of afghanistan if you want to
sideline here you're not just sideline
side lying
herself it is just like you want to
eradicate her hope her future whatever
she has the plan for the for the afghans
and what the achievements that he had in
the last 20 years is just you know like
removing hair so the same like her we
have like thousands of the people in
this country where they suffered a lot
here distracted a lot it's not easy for
them to be removed from the society or
the way that they want to work so
there's
islam has given them the rights we have
to give them their rights this is their
basic need like
right now millions of girls are out of
the schools they're deprived there's no
any hope for them to return back they
were given promises that they will
return back to the schools they returned
on the day where they were promised but
they sent them back
with like thousands of the people
millions of peers with with the teary
eyes they went back to their homes with
no hope for them so this is not the way
to go or you know it's better to be very
practical it's better to be to think you
know like we have to uh adjust ourselves
with the reality of today and the
reality is that this generation that is
talking to you is totally different from
the generation that they were rolling
back in 1996 to 2000 so we are not ready
to accept the things that contradict
both the culture and our religion
and will stand we will resist as long as
we can do it we know that there may
there might be many threats there might
be many rest but if we do not accept
rest today it means that we are going to
uh surrender very easily and we are
going to give up very easily it's
something that we don't want to be we
have to make a change altogether we do
not want to oppose them with any form
with any means but as long as the
decrees the
announcement contradicts islam and
culture we will stand we don't
i i don't think that i'm i'm scared of
anything anything happens it's okay
let's happen but let the other
generation which comes after us at least
live in peace and prosperity and dignity
with what we are doing today and that's
what i hope if they
uh they're watching the interview they
are doing you should consider that we
are not the generation that they were
ruling back in 1997 where change we have
different mentality we want to all
together want to peace or live in peace
and coexistence and work for a better
country that's what we want from them
and that's what let's contribute let's
not oppose each other this is the match
that we have by issuing our train you
cannot constrain this limit you will
admit it to maybe in a village for a
very short span of time
but in the long term this is something
that is not that might be not good for
their government and if you want to
govern you're governing us the people
the nation if the nation is not
uh
from here they do not want to coordinate
with you the the behavior that you have
i'm not sure that any government can
survive without their nation or uh or
without having a very close relationship
this is not
what i mean is like let's let's let's
support each other let's uh let's let's
uh take a very close look at the reality
of our today
let the women get back to their jobs
so they have been wearing hijab they're
already asking them people we are
muslims from long back and
our female
women have been we are in hijab
practicing islam from very long back
it's not like this is the first day of
one year or two years that we we are
practicing in islam this is not the way
it's just you know like they are making
pretexts in order to work to to remove
women i hope they consider these things
let the women get back to their life let
them enjoy their freedom that the god
has given them the islam has given them
let the girls come back to schools
millions of years of waiting just for us
a decree asking them to return to this
school there are millions of people it's
not only millions of people there are
millions of hops millions of
of lives you know
uh
yeah these are what we want from them
and i hope they consider we are
supportive but we are from the same
nation we are the same people if you
don't join hands together i don't think
that
we will survive or they will survive
and i hope they watch this and
and and reconsider or revive their
decisions or their degrees that they are
ordering what they have been issuing and
since they took over that the
international community knows the world
knows that they are just
issuing
decrease on women issues only there are
so many other subjects come on let's
check on let's let's work for those
things as well let's get rid of
the bigger problems that you have why
woman's already i don't know no one is
asking him why women know me
i have watched your interview with soil
shine she has two daughters both of them
are going to school both of them attend
school they may have a better future
maybe in the other countries but people
like fire that will be sitting here
where she's as i tell like studied more
than 20 years
she will she will just you know like end
it up with having no future with nothing
but it's kind of a double standard we
have to understand that
we know that their
children offspring or going to schools
attending universities international
kind of thing but we do not have this
right to go to our school inside the
country this is what we don't expect
then we don't want at any cost this
generation will oppose it at any cost
even if it costs our life will stand no
matter what happens at the end
well hamid and freda thank you very much
indeed for joining me i admire your
courage enormously as fellow journalists
i think it's disgraceful what is going
on in your country i think it's
disgraceful the way we abandoned your
country
i think it's horrendous the way that
women are being treated and as hamid
said there are many other horrendous
issues going on as well but uh i admire
both of you for what you've been doing
it takes a lot of guts to do this and i
wish you all the very best so thank you
for joining me
thanks for having us